all right Sean you want to tell me about
yourself
um yeah where'd you grow up
I grew up on 11th and Hoover in Los
Angeles California I was born in
Hollywood Presbyterian Hospital May 10
1956. I'm an only child
always went to parochial schools
um during the summer and we had summer
Care at the same schools I went to
I was never allowed to play with the
neighborhood children
um what was your family like
my father was Irish my mother was
English she was a a technical editor my
father was an electronic engineer
um
I was a middle class environment we
didn't dress really nice and we had all
the things like for school books a lot
of learning we kind of lived in a crappy
place but that was a
mixed neighborhood at the time a lot of
Mexicans a lot of Latinos and I really
don't particularly care for them either
I can't stand that music it just woo
um
there wasn't any drugs in the
neighborhood then at that time
um
then everything was pretty cool at the
house
um my father died when I was 16 and that
was the end of my childhood and that was
the death of my prince
when my father died my life went
I was looking for affection and love in
all the wrong places I discovered all
the
Bad Boys
that went to like Belmont
berendo you know all the bad schools
that you hear about
um discovered sex
not drugs drugs were weren't my thing at
that point
um
my mother kind of caught on that there
was something strange going on at the
house she got another job to replace my
father
um so she was in home from seven o'clock
in the morning until 11 o'clock at night
and this was back in the 70s early 70s
so I took good advantage of that
um boys boys more boys
um
of course I always did very good in
school and that was how I got rewarded I
got books and got to go on trips and
and not as much discipline not as much
watching me all the time
um
then I went to USC and I kind of got
back on the straight and narrow
um
my father's Social Security and veterans
benefits paid for that and then my
mother bought me a car
I was 21 years old
I didn't have a job my mother supported
me bought my insurance
you know and so I discovered boys but
not any boys black boys because USC is
full of wonderful football players
and I like them black and I like them
buff
um
so
I stopped going to school I got a job
full time at the vet that's where I met
the baby's daddy as we see it now
um he wasn't into drugs at that point
but he soon discovered crack and that is
when I got pregnant with my youngest son
my oldest son excuse me and he started
beating on me I became his private
punching bag
so
eventually
I got a restraining order he went to
prison and
that was the end of that but that made
life worse because then I had discovered
crack and I knew how to get it I knew
how to rock it up but I knew how to do
all these things with it but I also had
to be a mother
and I wasn't a very good mother
I'd rather spend the week at the Hayes
Motel on Jefferson Central then take
care of my own children
um
so
this habit I acquired for crack
it was devastating not only to my
physical and mental and spiritual needs
but I can learn my children and soon I
was just like a cracker
but I had to keep it on the dialogue
because I still lived at home and I
still had my boys and I had to keep it
quiet before they told their other
grandmother and then one time they did
and she tried to take the children
so
one thing led to another and I got a
co-defendant an aha gangster [__] and he
knew how to rock it up he knew where we
could go get it
and so it was this more convenient for
having him to go do it
um I'm a very lazy drug addict I'd
rather have you go get it bring it home
put it in the pipe so I don't have to do
any work
um
well
I I had always resented my mother
because she never got to let me say
goodbye to my father when he was dying
and at 16 that's very important to a
young girl
um especially since I was an only child
and so um
it got to be that the violence you could
see it like bubbling like a volcano that
it was going to erupt so so one morning
I asked her for like fifty dollars sixty
dollars something like that and she told
me no and she had never said no that
emphatically
so um I could have been says well
where's the money I said she told me no
so
um he had bought a
three 57
type of guns during the Rodney King
riots so it was in the house
but I didn't know that the night before
we had stayed up all night smoking that
he had prepared there
like um
mask to put on a mask piece of duct tape
to put over her mouth so when he
commends to doing whatever he was going
to do she wouldn't scream we had the gun
ready so
um
when she told me no I you know just kind
of slept it off and then
he uh
broke it like broke in her room because
she lived downstairs and
and I didn't really stop him when he
commenced to beating her and because
I was still so angry about her not
letting me say goodbye to my father and
instead of being a loving daughter
I was just
wanted money and I wanted dope and I
really didn't care what he did
um so he
ran away from the house went down to the
where the Crypt thing at the 83rd
and Western where the original Rodney
King Riot had started
and we hit out there for a while
and
people always ask you didn't she miss
your mother and I said well I was
actually glad to get rid of her I didn't
have to listen to her scream and holler
and yell and all kinds of things it just
irritated me
um
being high on drugs you just went quiet
you just want people to just give you
your stuff and leave you alone
and
took me a long time to um
get over that took me a long time to
realize that I had brutally slain and
murdered my own mother
um you did it or you're well we both
kind of did it together he he put he
actually shot her while I held her down
so push comes to show it was a 50 50 uh
you had that much hatred for your mom
yes
because she would not let me say goodbye
to my father when he the last week of
school I went to Catholic school she
wouldn't let me go see him and I thought
that was very strange because I always
went to go see him after school
and he goes well she goes not this week
they're doing tests and stuff on them
but my girlfriend's fathers were
ministers and they had gone to see him
and they knew that he was dying
that they told their daughters not to
say anything because it must be a reason
that my mother's not letting me go see
him you know so
I'm just had that much anger that much
resentment towards her
because he was my prince he was what
kept my sanity in that house
but it's always me and my dad that hung
out my mother was like a
a pledge uh
I'm trying to say it like a
um someone that didn't even belong in
the house her
her personality didn't jive with my dad
and I were real happy go lucky and all
that and my mother was always so serious
and
always criticized my dad and yelled at
him and I resented that because that's
what I thought he died of cancer and you
know later on down the road they
discovered that stress can cause cancer
so I assumed that my mother did it you
know and I had a lot of unresolved
issues
from also
I didn't particularly care for her
mothering
um
skills and so I kind of copied him I
yelled at my kids and I didn't pay
attention to them so it was like one
generation following the other
generation
um
so
I went to prison
and uh I was sentenced to 16 to life
second degree murder and of course I got
loose in prison that I had killed my
mother and they really
it took me a while to
for them just to leave me alone I'm not
that I used any anger I just didn't
acknowledge their existence I just
ignored their
um stupid questions I ignored their
statements
and I went through life
in prison like that for a long time like
15 years for murder for murder because I
murdered my mother
and then I wondered why my children
didn't want anything to do with me
well it doesn't take a genius to figure
that out you know you killed their
grandmother
and um my middle son to this day has not
forgiven me for my mothering skills he
really could care less that I killed his
grandmother we're using drugs at the
time oh no it's high as a kite
um
but he was mad that I did not mother him
according to him
how he thought I should be mothering
them
you know um
I use them as suitcases I drug them all
over town I got money you know I would
ask my mother for money we're gonna go
do this that I kind of used him like a
bartering chip
so that I could do things that I wanted
to do
um
but eventually
through
a lot of oh
soul searching
um
remembering that my mother didn't have
to have me my mother didn't have to do
any of the things that she did for me I
went to USC for God's sakes
she didn't have to do any of that
and so I learned to think of her in a
different way
I learned to think of her as she did the
best that she could do with what she had
she was raised during the Depression and
let me tell you my my grandmother was a
piece of work she was very very uh
conservative
she made sure that things were run the
way she wanted them to run this was her
third husband that of course
that she had outlived so she was the the
head rooster the head head and so we she
did things my mother did things the way
her mother did and then I did things the
way she did so it's like a generational
we didn't communicate with our kids we
just don't sit down shut up and never
gave him a reason why
um
well eventually you hear the old story
God came into my life you hear this from
everybody that goes to prison
um but in my case
I had been to parochial schools all my
life I knew there was a God I knew that
it was certainly not obeying his rules
and certainly not behaving the way I was
supposed to be
but eventually
he slapped me in the face and said if
you ever want to go home and see your
children you have to behave in a
different manner you have to think in a
different manner you have to address
people in a different manner you have to
ah
be nice to people
you have to accept them for who they are
not for who you want them to be
and so that took me a good five or ten
years
after I did that so that was why I spent
27 years in prison on a 16 to life
sentence because I did not say or do
what the board of prison terms wanted me
to say and do
but fortunately for me I was a big girl
so nobody really bothered me much in
prison about violence and beating me up
and
because I kind of hung out with the
lifers that we had our groups and we
we showed compassion towards each other
but anybody outside our group no he did
not
um
eventually my children started coming
around my oldest and my youngest son
came to visit me in prison what a
wonderful day
um
they cried I cried everybody cried and
they were going to Loyola High School at
that point
um
so
the sisters you know made a big thing
about them seeing their mother
um and that I had finally come around
and Anthony was just so proud of me that
I was no longer
just asking for things because I thought
I deserved them I would ask for things
because I needed them or I had earned
them or
I had a job for Pia I really didn't need
money I mean sure that
I was situated so I didn't have to take
anything from them but before I went
into prison and before I
that when I before when I got arrested I
wanted everything I wanted people to
give me everything so my whole thinking
had this change in order for me to
become a better person
in order to
face Freedom when I got out I've been
out less than three years
I have a job
as I was telling you
um I have a place to stay
and my two of three
two of
three of my boys are back in my life
um
I just got accepted into the church that
they go to
I'm getting baptized April 1st
things are going
good for me in a spiritual way
I just can't leave the crystal mess
alone that is my one
thing how many years you've been using
it well on and off uh I snorted it in
prison
and I didn't like it because it made me
tweak I mean I took things apart that I
couldn't put back together and I'm
usually not that type of person I don't
like to take things apart I really don't
even like oil and nasties I'm a really
girly girl
um
so I'd quit that and then I discovered
smoking it I want smoking it's wonderful
stay up all night you know the sex is
wonderful you know but
you have to come to that point that
all those are superficial things you're
destroying your body I have COPD I have
no business smoking crystal meth
you know I have no business smoking
cigarettes
because you can hear it in my voice
that raspy smoker kind of coughing and
talking
but I can't I just can't quit it because
it keeps me calm and I don't understand
why because it should not keep me calm
it should be just the opposite
but I'm thinking that
I try I mean oh I really try and then
working down here
on the street I work on and they sell
crack up and down all night long I don't
even like to smell and crash anymore
because it gave me that 27 years of no
kids no no Freedom that I wanted to do
you know you have to
sit and you know clean out your locker
if they want you to move you're under
someone else's constant supervision do
you blame crack cocaine for why you
committed that murder
hell yes
I would never have done anything like
that I mean I'm not particular I wasn't
particularly fond of my mother and I
used to call her a [__] to her face all
the time but murder is very different
and my father was around he controlled
us he kind of now you two Sean go to
your room and Clara leave her alone
she's 15 years old God knows how many
hormones and all that other stuff is
going on and you want to tell her to be
what be quiet how old were you when you
murdered her 25
I was 16 when he died and I think that
was definitely the beginning of the end
at my house
because he stabilized everything he made
everything okay he kind of made
Christmas okay he made birthdays okay my
mother hated Christmas she thought
birthdays were a waste of money you know
she wanted new books she wanted to buy
me new books which were expensive but
they were for school screw the new
dresser if you wanted to look like
everybody else I was always feeling
inferior I was always feeling like I
didn't belong
because I didn't look like everybody
else
I'm a big girl
my mother would keep my hair like short
and she I just think she made me ugly on
purpose
she'd buy me dresses that didn't fit it
was just like her
the older I got the more I would analyze
it in a negative way
I didn't realize how hard she was
struggling to keep me in private school
to make sure I could go to these Museum
trips and make sure I could have all
these added educational
bonuses
I got a car when I was 21. you know
there's not very many kids here mother
says what kind of car would you like I
said I want that blue one walked drove
it right off the lot
I didn't have to pay for gas I didn't
pay for my own insurance nothing was
just like everything was given to me
with the understandings that
I behaved the way she wanted me to
behave I got good grades in school
um didn't bring the wrong kind of boys
home
the first black boy I bought home I
thought my mother was going to have a
heart attack
and you can imagine when I had Anthony
James and Patrick the first Anthony she
I thought she was going to have a hernia
heart attack
but you know
life changes her [__] was
those were her babies you didn't talk
about them you didn't say they were
anything bad about them because they
were black
you know there was like a learning
experience for her it was like
God was trying to teach me to accept my
mother through the way that she accepted
my children
and it took me a long time to figure
that out it took me a long time as why
did why did I have those children why
did I have my sons you know why did she
love them so much when sometimes I
doubted she loves me
but the violence that I had towards her
was I was so angry and so
upset with her for keeping me away from
my father
I didn't care if he didn't understand
what I was saying I just wanted to be in
his presence
and then when we buried him oh no I
didn't like the suit I didn't like the
coffin I wanted the pillow I wanted him
that they fixed their makeup I mean I
went crazy
because that was the only way I could
show how I felt because I didn't know
how to communicate it but I could show
you how I felt but I couldn't tell you
how I felt
it was uh
and that was before I started using
drugs and after I started using drugs I
really couldn't communicate
because what was the point I had the
money to buy the drugs I usually had a
boy that would help me go buy them so
what did I need for what did I need to
be nice to them for
you know it was just a this is a way I
functioned in life because that was the
way
I got what I wanted are you able to be
functional as a crystal meth addict and
so what Crystal as a crystal meth addict
yeah I'm okay with that
um my oldest son and my kids aren't
really into drugs at all so they really
don't catch on to what I'm doing now my
landlord he knows the hell when I
sometimes he goes Sean are you okay
he goes you're acting funny
and I said I'm okay he goes why are you
so dehydrated I said I take all those
pills
so I have to calm him down once in a
while do you go days without sleep
no I sleep well I do now because I work
this weird shift but I can't stay
updated but Crystal Maxwell crystal meth
can keep you up for days not me I can go
to sleep
I can take a hit and go to sleep
because my body is so opposite because
of your ADHD I think it's my hours the
way I
even with crack I would go to sleep
sometimes people that are ADHD I think
yeah on crack well yeah it'll behave
differently yeah it'll call Behavior
because I take Prozac so I have you know
um those what do you call it when you
can't stand noises
um
a d
uh it's not attention this deficit is
like a
oh I can't my sudden noises people are
crack bubble gum or pop that bubble wrap
or you know do something that makes a
sudden noise it scares me you're jumpy
huh you're jumpy I'm very jumpy
and people notice that my God son you're
scared I said I can give a [__] that's
the noise bothers me
yeah
and I don't like I like things the way I
like them
you know I want a man but do I really
want a man
no because they don't never on time
don't do what I want to do you know how
old do you know sick I'm 66 I'll be 67
in May
looking back at your life what would you
have done differently if you could
well I would have appreciated my mother
much more
and I would not have gone as crazy
perhaps if I had known
there my mother couldn't help the way
she was raised
because my grandmother couldn't help the
way she was raised and it's a
generational thing my grandmother was
born before the depression my mother was
born during the Depression and lived on
a farm
you know no TV
but she had a radio and she loved her
radio it's just that she was so
completely opposite of what I liked
and what I like to do
um
she was an exercise nut she liked to
walk everywhere I hate to walk
you know it's just the little things it
was like oh
she was trying to mold me the way she
wanted me to behave the way she thought
I should behave
and then she would give me like a car
[Music]
um
I don't know that's awful bad to get
money a car
it's not gonna have sex anywhere now you
know and that was my thing
it's between
I usually find boys or men
that I like to have sex with but they
usually use drugs
so but at this point in time I don't
need them to buy my drugs I don't need
them to buy anything else because I know
how to do it all myself
but I want them to be on time I want
them to call me when I call them and
leave a message I want them to behave a
certain way but
they don't
because they don't have to
because they're [__] too
they're all manhorse
and once you start investigating them oh
Lord have mercy they're really men
[__]
you know and they know how to just know
how to twist it
go out with this one now we had broke up
when I lived in Venice and got anything
to do with him came down and saw me on
Halloween not Halloween Thanksgiving
where I work now oh telling me how much
you missed me and adored me and blah
blah blah blah blah within two weeks we
were smoking crystal meth really dated
black men
I only go out with Blackness you've
never tried oh yeah a long time ago
but it doesn't do anything it doesn't
because they don't want to put up with
the bossiness sometimes the black guys
that put up with the bossiness because
they always know they're going to get
some money
yeah I'm kind of uh is it really about
the money for them
expensive habit I'll buy a hundred
dollars at a time I don't buy no 20 I'm
not going back there I buy a hundred
dollars at a time and I'll maybe smoke
it for a month because I don't share my
joke but the guys you're dating the guys
I'm dating oh I'll give them a hundred
dollars and they go do something with it
I don't care what they do
yeah I've gone and gone to sleep at
their house for like six hours
the phone's ringing off the hook
um again they have message the thing oh
so so-and-so to call so and so
his Facebook page is Fuller
[__] but I think it's in the
relationship with you for the money uh
probably
but we both work at the same place
but he's got children and he has to pay
rent I don't pay 75 bucks a month right
I don't and I don't support my kids
they're in their 40s I don't have to
decide to worry about myself
and sometimes he's cool sometimes he
ain't
but I tell him I said don't [__] with me
because I murdered my mother does not
mean I won't murder you
so I best not catch you in my face
[__] these [__]
you know uh
she does I never heard you talk like
that I said well you treat me like you
know you're never on time I call you and
you never call me back that's rude
but I put up with it
because I'm desperate for a man
so I really don't like women that much
you know
I don't know just Twisted kind of so
kind of a Twisted Sister
John what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
end of yourself
for all your needs and go to God
because he is the only one that will
keep you on the straight and Daryl
in my in my book in my opinion uh
other people have other things that they
do to keep them on the straight and
narrow
um
I like to crochet I like to act like an
old lady and I got two cats and I
crochet and
and then sometimes I stay up all night
smoking crystal meth because it's just
it's there
and it calms me so much
I'll be like oh my God I can't wait to
get home one more homeless person asked
me for something I'm gonna kill him you
know
I've had five phones stolen you know
because I'm not used to watching my
things so much
you know I'm kind of
lack of days ago
you work down here helping the homeless
mm-hmm
and I'm getting sick of that because
I made twenty dollars an hour doing that
and that's the only reason I do it
because some of them are very sweet some
of them are very compassionate and some
of them are very caring but the rest of
them
they all want some they all want
something they want to get you before
you get there
and so I could just see it when they ask
you for something
you know sometimes they're very
they know that I know so they kind of
make it in a circle you know like oh are
you gonna eat that oh no I'm not here oh
are you gonna use that then they get
bigger and bigger when you say yes to
let's say an orange pretty soon they
want what's in your bag or drink your
water or eat your chips or whatever
something so small
but that's not the way life does mean
these days
I work hard for my stuff and I work hard
to stay clean and sober when I'm around
my kids
um I've discovered that church is almost
as good as crystal meth for calming my
nerves
almost
and I tried to my oldest son is so proud
of me for being on a prison having a job
having a place to stay you know I mean
he says may not be much mother but it's
your own
so you know he's very so is real estate
has a Tesla he's like my
my road dog
because my all my friends these guys
have seen him you know with the Tesla
where'd you get a Tesla from I said
that's my son's sales real estate he
lives in Lamarck Park God damn son he's
very successful
yeah
and he's almost whitewashed he's so
successful
I just have a
lot of strange ways about thinking
things about thinking about things
but if I exclude God oh I'm worse
so I always have to keep him I mean God
the things I've done and he's forgiven
me for and let me go on with my life
I don't even deserve to be alive I don't
think
but sometimes I can be a terrible person
I'll talk to people anyway I please
because what I got the money
I have the power
you know
it's the way I was brought up
all right Sean thank you so much for
sharing your story did I do what I was
supposed to do yes you did okay